[Music]
i think cars should come with health
warnings like cigarettes
[Music]
why consider this
what cigarette do you smoke doctor it
might sound
incredible now but there was a time when
doctors appeared in adverts
encouraging us to smoke you could smoke
in restaurants and pubs
buses and planes now cigarette packets
come with stark and graphic warnings
about the impact of smoking on your
health and on
those around you in the future will we
look back on this era
the rise of the car with similar
incredulity
i think so during the height of the
coronavirus lockdown
daily emissions of carbon dioxide fell
by 17
around the world 17 million tons
less carbon dioxide was emitted every
day
with almost half of that drop because of
fewer car journeys
air pollution in some uk cities dropped
by as much as 60 percent
there are more than a billion cars
around the world
and as we reassess and restructure our
world
i think we need to reassess our
relationship you could call it a love
affair
with the car what's interesting about
our response to the threats from both
smoking and the pandemic
is how we acted and changed our behavior
to help protect each other's health
we don't blow cigarette smoke in each
other's faces anymore
or light up inside
with the coronavirus we quickly learned
to give each other space
wear masks wash our hands and we got
used to all the signs reminding us to do
so
it's normal when there's a threat to
life for us to change our behavior
and to do whatever it takes to protect
friends family and other people
so why do we put up with the air
pollution pandemic
when there's something that we can do
about it
why don't we have reminders on cars
about the consequences
of street level pollution and encourage
us to walk or cycle more
still not convinced here are a few
things you need to be aware of
when it comes to cars studies have shown
air pollution
much of which comes from cars
contributes to the premature deaths of
almost
half a million people in europe every
year
the impact on our bodies is truly
frightening
air pollution can trigger heart attacks
strokes and asthma
and contribute to stunted growth low
birth weight
and lung cancer car tire wear
also contributes hugely to air pollution
but it's a largely
unregulated area as you drive on the
road
your car tires shed tiny bits of tyre
material
micro plastics which get washed into our
drains
and ultimately our rivers and oceans
this happens regardless of whether your
car
is diesel petrol hybrid or electric
and there's another big problem with
cars
and that's their impact on climate
change
you only have to drive 500 meters in an
average modern car
to melt at least one kilo of glacier ice
since 2010 suvs have been the second
biggest source of rising carbon
emissions
if suv drivers were a nation they'd be
the world's
seventh biggest carbon polluter
every time you use your car you're
contributing to the degradation
of the planet a lot of this is just
unnecessary
here in the uk even when trips are only
between
one and two miles long three kilometers
six out of ten people
still drive in circumstances
no one would ever have wished for the
coronavirus pandemic
gave us a small glimpse of what a
different cleaner
greener less polluted world could be
like
putting health warnings on cars could be
a stark and clear
visual reminder to all of us about the
devastating
impact they have on both people and the
planet and help shift our attitude to
cars
once and for all
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification
each time we upload a new video